questo mi è difficile subito difficile
lo si dovrà farsi fa perché si spiega
non l'ho avuta io perché sennò non
sarebbe fregato un episodio di akin ator
dove noi sfidiamo ci sediamo tra di noi
ma ci sfidiamo a chi network in che
senso se voi ci pensate al retro è
incredibile perché indovina ciò che voi
state pensando cosa che è sempre
esistita come gioco tra di noi pensa chi
indovina visto pensa e quindi oggi
contiamo le domande che noi facciamo tra
di noi per indovinare un personaggio e
poi vediamo se riusciamo a battere a chi
network e sullo stesso personaggio
ok io ho pensato a due persone lui ha
pensato due persone vediamo quanto ci
mettiamo interinali e poi chiediamo da
fine per cui non totale ci saranno 4
personaggi della pallina
esatto ok by però tu vai casa vai bros
il personaggio reale no il personaggio è
preso da unanime ma anche perché il
personaggio di un videogioco se è il
protagonista di un videogioco e il co
protagonista in b del gioco no è
l'antagonista no
e in un gruppo di una band di un
videogioco di una ben intendo web una
gang no allora che hai fatto le prime
tre domande in 3d di incredibili e il
resto no è anche un film
se questo personaggio superpoteri
certo se è un super umano no e dei
pokémon si è questa
e tra i pokémon più famosi si è trovato
il fa domande molto generalizzanti ma
che ti permettono di tagliare via
tantissime cose quindi la domanda stata
innanzitutto è maschio femmina questa
taglia a metà tutto tu sapendo che un
pokémon che domande fi per tagliare dia
la maggior parte dei pokémon o comunque
una gran fetta per dario si ok ok bene è
a forma di cane si sputa fuoco e quindi
si domanda perché non è male che la
raduna se tu avessi azzeccato poche ma
non la porta la guida era difficile mai
potevi farlo alla settimana indovinato
buonissimo e reale se maschio se io lo
conosco il bordeaux una sorta di legame
con questa persona
milano adesso tutti su milano stupido
mettere di messina no l'ho conosciuto
tramite te no l'ho conosciuto tramite
marco se ieri sera la frase è pelato
no dai una maniera e viene soltanto
l'aspetto è un doppiatore noah
disabilità mamma maria mere piombo sì ma
proprio avatar
alla quarta e non è di milano ai giovani
dove l'ho conosciuto io la ricordo
essere strumenti perché non l'ho detto
io per primo ho detto mo vedere così
banale ma vai locale ente i 15 ei rumors
13 quindi deve fare devi aver fatto
meglio di aki netto però prima di testa
lucky nator tornate poi ci sono arena
allora è una persona sia reale si valori
dove si italiano sì lo conosco si fa
video gameplay si sa più di milioni
iscritti
sì ma mai kraft
no si ha un fratello che fa video si è
ciccio gamer si quante di esse ok bandai
è andata anche male si deve andare molto
meglio che io lo penso
ok e raisi meno molto easy ma è una
persona
sì ma reale si fa musica
no è un attore sì io lo conosco di
persona
no in italiano no affatto una serie tv
non ho avuto un film che come se sono
fan di questo film tanto si entra la
magia si o il protagonista daniel
hackett canio barco musici niente io non
dai allora non siamo messi male io sono
un po ritardato la figlia basta
sono gli dico faccio schifo a giampiero
sono spuntati i baffi eletto ha perso la
barba no alla verità è che avevamo
registrato la seconda parte di questo
video però no no veniamo universo
parallelo e abbiamo sepolto i nostri
beppegol cornell giardini ha reso no e
quindi dobbiamo parte la seconda parte
del video la facciamo adesso lui è un
giampiero un po più messicano e io sono
un influente perché nel nostro mondo
l'influenza si chiamano influence on
ci hanno detto che i nostri soci a
avevano fatto entry con 15 domande che
era mio è tuo e il 2012 domanda è se si
stesse il rumors con 13 ciccio gamer lo
indovinato io con 10 e da né ad altri
complici
è il momento di vedere signori se a chi
layton riesce in qualche modo a fare
meglio dove sono diventato famoso grazie
al carico diamo deve fare meno di 15 per
battere giampiero ok nella famosa grazie
calcio non gioca a pallone su due gambe
a entrambi gli occhi se si è reale non è
reale ma con fare con atenei tornassi se
lo zucchero come of the mood for power
to the people ha chiesto anche fare
niente allora pokémon
siamo a meno della metà gara è caduto un
po più verde ok
celebri no no mi piace o non voglio
farlo di battaglia il nuovo leggendario
sia attenzione ora vogliono arriva
voglio farlo a che fare con la serie the
video star trek no perché dove si fanno
a che fare con i lupi
no non è un cane leggenda rane no no no
attenzione no
ok sembra una donna no no ho capito a
che fare con tecnico e piace come nonno
a che fare con fortunate un po che o non
è più vabbè andiamo direttamente alla
domanda finale mi piace che a chi netto
il campo quando aderisce fa domani
quindi un po con la sito di leggendario
anzi quindi quello di fuoco per quindi
ha recitato nel mondo di patty ancora
indossa vestiti io l'ho visto anche
l'uso se non è anche io sì a regime
meglio non sapere se avete visiva dragon
ball beh no non so noi 6 resiste a
torino fa parte di un anime vorrebbe un
sacco già perché no potrebbe non è un
film non ancora ai capelli capelli cento
dei bei capelli ed è bene purtroppo no
a parte il gioco purtroppo serate
l'italia sini ieri e più di tre abitato
cittadino ancora più bella è
consigliabile che subi to the sea
destino no non è comunque già perso 3 se
ti conosce dobbiamo e torino anche se si
è un cantante no ma è continuo
[Musica]
beh diciamo che però secondo la tra i
due secondo me ci danno da fare entrambi
cc si dà da fare entrambi però secondo
me no anche secondo me non è una prova
nè l'uno nè lui e lei torna diretto ai
falli ha vinto giampiero adesso se io
perdo che ci ho messo melo è ciccio
gamer il tuo personaggio esiste davvero
sì sì sì cc esiste personale nazionalità
italiana si romano se non so ma è stato
scoperto grazie a youtube si sa che il
mondo dei videogiochi 6 ago lama data
non fa finta di camminare sull'erba
certo ogni tanto lo fa perché fare con
forte lightsey si fa video caso
fidanzata
no niente apposta ma l'abbiamo chiamato
ciccio ciccio merino bene ha fatto nella
ce l'ha fatta però con 16 questo yacht
daniel radcliffe è a prossimo tra 0 e
100 ragazzi e genitori non ci tiene e
reale si si indossa abiti maschili si
famoso grazie di tutto non ce lo vedrei
arriva più di 35 anni
ma non ti conosce l'italiano è un attore
gli ex fa parte ha sete diceva no no dio
mio dio mio vero ruolo di mag in via
ammazzo io mi abbasso la vecchia
giampiero santoro io credo all'orecchio
tagliate non tanto per la vittoria 13
bellissimo tanto così bello è che volevo
40 computer non ci sei non ci sei però
ci stavi credibile ragazzi sono
veramente orgoglioso di noi umani contro
a chi nator piccolo gli umani l'essere
umano ancora è superiore alle macchine
per ora performante
andatelo a dire a quelli detroit con il
vero che bisogna sia cresciuto ragazzi
iscritti al canale fateci sapere se
volete un altro test su a chi netto noi
lo faremo ciò chieder passante nei
social di giampiero che l'arci
descrizione e noi come sempre ai miei
non leggo io non ce l'ho anch'io sociale
destinata quindi a giampiero non ci sono
passate dai miei social che sono
descrizione schiacciate la campanella
per rimanere aggiornati i suoi video e
non ci vediamo poi se quello che dico
ogni volta che posso di montare bene
ragazzi a fare strano di tu lo sappia
perché resterà non aveva tenuto i video
a allora è giusto da ragazzi
[Musica]